now that shooting between the hell's
angel and a rival gang may have been in
retaliation for murder thank you for
joining us here at six i'm brian loftus
and i'm denise valdez six people shot
right on the 95 closing the freeway for
hours and today in court what may have
led up to all of this the 8 news now
i-team's david charns was in that
courtroom and david the judge saying
he's worried there could be even more
violence yeah denise and bryan the judge
making that statement after prosecutors
said sunday's shooting on the freeway in
henderson may have actually been in
retaliation for a murder last month all
involving the same motorcycle gangs
the concern for the state is that
what nobody ever wants to happen on the
freeways of las vegas happened here it
happened sunday a shootout on the 95 in
the middle of the day prosecutors
revealing thursday they believe the
shooting between the hell's angels and
the vagos was retaliation for murder
last month we know that a month back
about a month ago in san bernardino
avago still did kill the hell's angels
investigators alleging that boiled over
during a veterans memorial ride the
rivalry escalating on the 95 when police
say three men opened fire the president
of the las vegas chapter 66 year old
richard devries and two gang prospects
46 year old stephen allo and 26 year old
russell smith each facing multiple
charges including attempted murder one
of the bullets actually goes from where
the shooting is all the way across the
freeway all the way into an lds church
in a car prosecutors had asked the judge
to hold each man on a million dollars
bail their attorneys painting them as
stable citizens with no criminal records
we're dealing with a 66 year old
individual who is honorably discharged
from the military who has absolutely no
criminal record whatsoever many of
these members are veterans and
they are very clear
they've been super patriotic versus
disrespectful to it the judge agreeing
with prosecutors about possible further
violence jailing each man on nearly 400
thousand dollars cash i believe that
there is clear and convincing evidence
that
that
all of these these defendants are a
danger to the community
now those two attorneys who you heard
from there say that police have not
actually said who fired the bullets
though all three of those men face
attempted murder charge charges and
everybody is expected back in court in
this in less than two weeks i'm david
charns live local now